I think we should be doing business with
him I don't believe in eight because it
has been proven for the first fit last
50 years but it doesn't work but trade
invest in Africa let Africans change
their own destiny I lived in Kenya for a
long time and when a mass uprising
expressed in the form of demonstrations
comes about against the government the
government then violently put stuff down
now a number of the Africans that I
spoke to in we knew at the time would
say if Daniel arap Moi
did not have all this money that he is
getting from Britain and other Western
countries in aid he would not be able to
buy the weapons to crash us so that in
many African countries because of aid
the authoritarian figures there can't
afford to get the weapons and the money
to oppress their own government their
own people that's an issue that aid
workers simply don't want to deal with
and I think it's a she